the day that i literally woke up going
like oh
all of this everything is up to me all
of it
that was the day where i was like oh i
can do anything i can
do anything i want i can have the
muscles i want i can have the cardio i
want i can have the life i want
and it's it's all just entirely me um
that was a big big day for me and that
took a
long time of me still trying to put the
responsibility
into something else
on episode 87 of the michaela peterson
podcast
i'm joined by ethan suplee ethan suple
is an american actor
he's best known for his roles in the
films american history
x remember the titans the wolf of wall
street
without a paddle and several of kevin
smith's films
as well as frankie and boy meets world
and randy hickey in my name is earl
we discussed his incredible health
transformation he lost hundreds of
pounds and is quite a beast now
and we spoke about the distorted
relationships with food that many people
and americans have
and how sometimes what you eat might not
be the problem
we went pretty deep into the
relationship people can have with food
that can screw them up and what his
relationship with food has been
it was a good one he's an interesting
guy if you enjoy this episode
or learn something please remember to
hit subscribe this episode is brought to
you by
truelocal trulocal.ca
if you guys haven't checked them out you
really should because i'm not going to
stop mentioning them
the ceo is a friend and he's done an
amazing job with connecting local people
with local farmers
with all the negative vegan propaganda
going on and the misinformation
regarding quality meat
this is a company you can feel
comfortable using ethically and for
health
with trulocal you choose what meat cuts
go in your box
and they send it flash frozen to you
they have any meat you could possibly
want and even some organs
it's not the typical meat you'd find at
your local grocery chain
this is high quality ethically raised
meat and it tastes
great i recommend their grain-fed beef
wild salmon and their lamb is
probably the best lime i've ever had you
can even order some vegetables on there
now too if you're a vegetable eater
go to trulocal.ca and use code mp for
free steaks in your box
trulocal.ca code mp for free stakes i
hope you enjoy this episode
[Music]
ethan suplee welcome to my podcast thank
you for having me
i'm very excited to talk to you again
uh how are you doing i'm good i'm good
i've been uh i'm about to go do
a movie in mexico which
i uh it's it's odd having been
at home for so long the idea of going
away to work is
is a little bit weird but i'm looking
forward to it it's good that i
i have that opportunity again to go back
to work
yeah that's fun finally and you get to
get out of the country
and you get to go to mexico it's a bit
hot to go to mexico now but that sounds
good
can we start off by if anyone doesn't
know you by giving a brief background
about who you are and what it is you do
sure i'm an actor i uh
i've done a ton of movies from um
mall rats to remember the titans in
american history x and television series
like boy meets world
my name is earl and most recently chance
which was on hulu and uh and i also have
a podcast called the american glutton
podcast
what does the american glutton podcast
get into
it's it's almost all about
um
kind of the way i find our culture
deals with food and
any kind of addictive things that can be
associated with that
or even just like i'm just super
interested in
everybody how people eat like i think
it's fascinating
how uh how divergent we are with
food and in in fairness i often
also think that a lot of it is
um very similar to kind of the way we
philosophically look at the world and
there's a bit more tolerance there
with how we treat each other it gets
it gets a little bit iffy when you get
into moral positions with like
veganism and stuff like that there
there's a very hard line
but i find that people who are
lactose intolerant and and
don't eat a lot of dairy are not really
angry at people who
want to have a cheese board for dessert
you know and and these i find these
things interesting
um a lot of it i also think is safe to
talk about because
these kind of um ideas are not
backed by any violence for the most part
you know
obviously you get into things like peta
and stuff and i'm interested in that too
i want to hear that point of view too
i just don't happen to hold it but i'm
totally open to hearing about it
interesting okay that's i would
recommend i've listened to some of your
episodes and i do like the podcast so
i would recommend checking that out if
people haven't heard about it
okay i'm gonna start with i have a whole
bunch of questions for you
um let's start a bit about your
background
how and when did you get into acting and
why
um okay how and when and why i was
i quit high school at 14.
i was not happy with school and um i got
into
some legal scrapes and
had some drug issues and
was basically like a delinquent
for a few years and i i lived in
hollywood and so i had friends who were
actors
and one of these actor friends said to
me
um like i think i think it was he had
some concern
for the way i was headed and he said you
should
you know i saw you in that school play
years ago you should come do my acting
class and and like be an actor and i was
like okay
that sounds like a good plan and i went
and
and started this acting class as at like
16.
and uh when i was 17 i started doing a
television
show called boy meets world um
the why was really just that i
i i enjoyed it and i had no other
real drive at the time you know
fair i mean you're only 16 so that's
pretty early
yeah um what was your favorite movie
that you've done
um my favorite movie that i've done
so far was cold mountain i thought it
was really
really well made and and i thought um
anthony mingela who also made
uh she's i'm blanking on
the talented mr ripley one of my
all-time favorite movies
and um and then cold mountain was this
real
i thought sprawling beautiful movie and
it was
it felt like something important to be a
part of i don't know if
um historically it will go down as an
important movie like i think
people consider remember the titans like
an important movie in
an american history x people think of as
an important movie and and i don't know
if
if cold mountain maybe gets lost in the
in the shuffle but i thought it was so
beautiful
okay i don't uh cold mountain i don't
know if i've seen cold mountain
yeah i don't think a lot of people have
um
it it it's based on a book and and i
might
by the way i say i think of it as so
beautiful i haven't watched it because i
don't watch things that i've done
but i have seen classics i feel that
yeah i've seen cl i've seen
pieces that i'm not in and and to me it
looks beautiful
and the book that it's based on is
spectacular
um and it's about um
it's about the civil war in a very
specific part of
of uh of the south um
and just kind of the lives of the people
who are left behind who who
who are still who are not like
participants in the war
but just living in small towns and
and their relationships and and i got uh
in the movie
i'm in a band with brendan gleason and
jack white
and we're this trio and like how [ __ ]
cool is that
that's pretty cool 2002 we're doing a
movie in romania
and jack white is like not a super mega
rock star yet and and he's playing
shows for the crew at little dive bars
in
in northern romania it was so awesome
okay that does sound like fun okay how
come you don't watch
what you're in um
i i i'm
so insanely critical of myself
and uh and i have no
power i i mean to say like
i have done a take in a movie and and
thought
god i did that so poorly i need to do it
again or
i have five variations on on the idea
that i was running with can we try all
of them
i've done that but once i get to the
point where
i'm a member of the audience if i see
myself first of all you're seeing
yourself in angles that you're
totally not used to seeing yourself and
i i'm accustomed to presenting myself in
the mirror
and like that's how i know myself and
suddenly if i
see myself from a weird behind side
angle
and i don't recognize myself and i've
was really obese for the majority of my
life it's this
jarring kind of thing you're confronted
with of like
oh my god that's [ __ ] me i i don't
understand
that view of myself and
so that was always difficult and then
the idea that by the time i'm
an audience member i have no power to
fix anything and so
every little thing that i see that i
that i think
i would have done that differently i i
wish i had another shot at that or i
wish they chose another take
it's so far out of my hands that i that
i find it
um not worthwhile okay
i kind of understand that i'm um i'll go
through if i make some sort of reaction
video i'll watch it pretty carefully
but for podcasts like i can't i can't go
back
and see and that's not even from other
angles so yeah
no i know i i get that yeah yeah you
hear i
i my voice cracked and um
i i stuttered and i stumbled and i used
the wrong word god i use the wrong words
sometimes and i'm like what a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
can i swear is this awful that i swear
no no no
okay no no you can do that yeah
it's tough it's tough going back and and
and then sometimes i go like okay it is
what it is
um and i should embrace it but
i i find that i have a battle within
myself
of um being
uh overly critical and then having to
walk myself through that and go like
hey dude shut up it's okay
yeah i get that that's kind of miserable
do you have any tricks for dealing with
that i tried very hard to find
something that even my uh
meanest most um self-effacing
judgmental version of myself can
accept as being at least decent and i
take that
and i build on it and i try to make a
foundation of like
you're not a piece of [ __ ] that's my
foundation and from that
i can i can find my way like a ladder
clinging to little bits
of like um
positivity to like feeling good about
myself
it does take work though it's not
something i find
innately i i'm incredibly jealous of
confident people
i had a conversation with my best friend
and she's just
she's just glowing with positive energy
all the time
and i was like you know when you look in
the mirror what do you see
and she's like i just think she's like i
have a problem because i just think i'm
awesome
all the time she's like even if i you
know spend the day in bed or i haven't
accomplished very much
i'm like yeah you know go you and i was
like that is
amazing that's amazing that there are
some people like that and then there are
some people that are like you know what
i could have done a little bit more
today
you know no matter what right which is
definitely not healthy but it's hard to
get past that if you're one of the
people who are just self-critical all
the time
yeah it really is the the little bit
more
today is so it i find that
there's a very fine line for myself
because no matter what i do
if i've if i've done the hardest workout
been absolutely perfect on my diet
gotten all my work
garbage that i need to get done done
even
like i've had days where i go to the gym
before work i work a 14-hour day
i don't cheat on my diet at work which
becomes very easy as an actor they're
constantly throwing food oh yeah yeah
and
and and then get home i spend time with
my kids
i take my dogs out for a walk i lay down
and there's still
stuff where i go like oh man if i just
gone around the block again
or if i just done a couple more sets of
bench press or whatever it is
and then i go shut the [ __ ] up dude you
do great
you had a great day so this this battle
but then there are days where
you know i have to um
remind myself of that because i don't
want to get out of bed
and and i have spent many days not
getting out of bed
and just kind of keeping the curtains
drawn
and being in a very dour mood
and and that kind of
wave i find that if i'm going in one
direction it's
easy to keep going in that direction um
and one s step back or one setback can
can be momentum in the other direction
that's so strong that
it it is difficult to overcome so
it's it's a tough thing you know again
like super confident people who
who move through life um with some kind
of effortlessness
uh it's enviable but it's just like
that's that's not the lot
i have so i have to kind of talk myself
through the irrationalities that i
that that that it's it is possible to do
you know you can't i can
manage to convince myself to get out of
bed most of the time which is good
do you think there are benefits for
being i mean
there's got to be some sort of spectrum
right because i feel like if you're
self-critical you can be self-critical
to a
fault but it also might enable
you to end up accomplishing more because
you have this horrible sense of guilt
when you don't do it so
what are your thoughts there do you
think there's a use for it i do
i totally think there's a use for it
from for me it's
very useful um it's so bizarre
how irrational i can find myself being
but like i'm
270 right now and in really good shape
and i've i've had days
where i was going in the opposite
direction with
weight and health and stuff like that
and felt and had these delusional
moments where i'm like yeah this
is great you know 350 is great and
and look at look at me i'm like feeling
really strong
um and i'm gonna have a pizza for dinner
and this whole thing and
and so there there i think there i think
there's a balance where you can
be self-critical to the point where it's
constructive
um i just think any of these things in
extreme
have not been useful for me but when i'm
thinking with that and going like stop
being so down on yourself
when you're doing well and stop being so
easy on yourself when you're not like
you gotta
try to see it's all kind of camouflaged
but we can
find it in that pattern um
something useful and workable if we're
like i found for me that
it's very useful to have goals and to
get really specific with my goals
and in doing that
if i'm if i'm hitting the markers that
are taking me to the goals
and still being super hard on myself
that's not useful
but if i'm missing them and i'm going
but it's okay
and making excuses then i need a little
bit of that no it's not okay
my my goals are not insane i have not
set the goal of being the
first you know uh unassisted human
in flight right this is not my lofty
imaginative creative goal so
what is my goal and if i'm not doing it
is it too outlandish do i need to reset
a goal or is it something that i'm just
being lazy about and then i need a
little kick in the butt
i think that's a really that's a that's
a really good idea for people who are
too critical about themselves
set small goals or or goals that you
think are reasonable and if you're
accomplishing them
then congratulate yourself instead of
saying i'm not doing well enough
yeah i i i completely agree
and and i i find that um
some of the nuances for me got lost in
this
early on because i would um
look at guys who impress for instance
i've always
i've always been a fan of cycling and so
i would look at
um lance armstrong was my idol he was
the guy who really made
cycling entertainment entertaining for
me and
i i was a little too young to be like a
greg lemon fan but then lance armstrong
came along and he was the guy and
i i would look at this and just
go like okay i'm gonna ride my bike up a
hill this was when i was very overweight
and
and if i didn't make it up to the top of
the hill
i would be so disappointed in myself but
i
have to go like did i did i try
did i did i do what i could do or was i
being lazy because there's a
there's a place in there for those right
if you're
if your goal is to ride the tour de
france which i think
is a really lofty goal um
you know and obviously i'm not even
talking about professionally just go
over and ride stages from the tour of
france these are incredibly hard things
to do
uh and you're down on yourself because
on day one of
training for this you can't make it up
to the top of the hill
it's like you got to be realistic about
what you're doing
did you get up did you get your did you
get on your bike did you get your ride
in if that's
all you needed to do that day that's all
you needed to do right if you're
you don't start out by doing 100 miles
or you know looking at guys like david
goggins
it's like it's like um
it can be it can be daunting but you
gotta realize like that guy that's what
that guy does
what's your version of that you know
yeah one of the problems i've had i
think is comparing myself
you have to choose who you compare
yourself to which is what you were just
saying
so if you just start out as something
and it's brand new
and you compare yourself to someone
who's been doing it for 40
years that's absurd right
like start a little bit smaller or at
least recognize the fact that
it took that person 40 years to get
there and if you're not
successful right away that's completely
normal i think that's a mistake people
make too
yeah 100 i would even use you as an
example
you have turned your life around through
nutrition
that's a big [ __ ] deal and i think a
lot of people
could benefit from that but if it's day
one for someone
and they start to adjust their nutrition
and whatever they're addressing eczema
or
ibs or who knows what or weight or
whatever it is
is not gone day one they're not a
failure you know what i mean like
yeah what was your goal for day one
making it through the day
did you make it through the day that's
that's like pat yourself on the back
a little bit okay i'm glad i'm glad you
brought that
up and i do want to segue into health a
little bit but yeah when i first started
my goals literally were to to make it
through the day
yeah like i did a day i really did a day
at a time
and it was horrible and it was horrible
for years
right so it definitely wasn't this
switch and when i
simplify it down in podcasts i say you
know
it took three months to get there or
take five months to get there it took
seven months to get there in different
stages every like day
of that period was terrible and then i
had ups and downs and things so i ended
up in a better place than i started
for sure and it was a fair it was a
it was a rocky road though it's not easy
so
segwaying into your health story because
you have an absolutely incredible
story can can we start off by um
i mean what were the battles you had
let's start with that
you know it's it's so
it's so kind of bizarre
to think about this because
i've i was overweight basically my whole
life
and i think when i think back to myself
as a
kid i wasn't so overweight that
um i was near sedentary or anything like
that
but then over time it just compounds and
it gets bigger and bigger
and and you know the day that i kind of
was confronted with everything it was
almost
as though i was unaware of it a moment
before
um the i the idea that my knees and my
feet
constantly hurt my back would go out i'd
slip
discs in my back a number of times
um that i sat down in in such a way
as to test the you know the tensile
strength of everything i was sitting on
for fear that i was gonna break it
having to have a washcloth in my pocket
at all times to mop my brow
which i would like in the middle of a
conversation with somebody kind of
turn and and do it as though they can't
see what i'm doing because i've done a
half turn away from them all of these
little things
you know you're unaware that this is
kind of unnecessary in your life that
that there is a solution to all of this
until the day that you wake up and you
go i have to change
and and i and i understand for people
you could have that thought a thousand
times and still
not do anything which i'm sure i did
and then there's just one day where it's
like i'm not going to
not think about this anymore this isn't
going to be something that i
allow to go to the recesses of my mind
or
i push away when it comes up you know
um and and then i
i started dieting it was about 2002
and and i say i started dieting i'd been
put on diets as a kid
my entire life i was on a diet there was
a period from
when i started working at 17 to
like 21 where or 22
where i wasn't on diets and that's where
my weight really exploded
but i was still started out at
350 pounds um
or maybe even close to 400 pounds uh
and then but but my point is my parents
always had me on a diet and then
the first time i decided to do a diet
where it was like i want
this change i'm going to do something on
my own that's not being enforced on me
it's not from an external
authoritarian point of view it's it's my
own determination
um i then
struggled for a long time because
i was trying to address
my relationship with food or what i've
come to understand as
my relationship with food by
looking for the food like
you you changed something that was
that you were allergic to basically that
was poisoning you
you cut that out i had this idea that if
i
found that that thing if i
if if it was a thing that was making me
this way and i just excised it that i
would be okay
which for me really took the
idea that i had a bad relationship with
food or an
unhealthy relationship with food again
just for myself i'm not saying that
anybody like me has exactly like i'm not
saying we're all the same but
i really did have this kind of terrible
relationship
with food and so i i eventually
worked my way into confronting that and
looking at like
oh you know if i if i'm going like
late at night i'm gonna go to the
drive-through and eat
a meal for six and i'm just gonna do
that
same thing have that exact same behavior
but i'm gonna take the buns off the
burgers
this is still not gonna be successful
for me
um because i need to look at what i'm
doing with food that's unhealthy versus
the idea that
it's just some part of the food that's
causing this to happen to me does that
make sense
yeah it does okay uh how did you
so do you have suggestions for how
people could identify whether or not
it's like most of the people i well work
with or or talk to
have some sort of like autoimmune
disorder or something and what i focus
on is
it's what you're eating that's the
problem it's not
the relationship right i haven't really
gone into the relationship
is there a way that you can identify if
that's what your problem
is i think so and i think these are
these are really two distinctly
different things that
some people could be experienced
experiencing both of them i think that's
possible
i think i probably experienced both of
them to be honest yeah
i think that um
there there is certainly auto autoimmune
disease
and there's a host of of things that we
would not want to happen to our body
simply by ingesting things that our body
cannot
process right that is very distinctly a
thing
um and then you can also have a
relationship with food where you're just
eating too much you know and so
i would find like the thing i was
wanted to address the only thing i
wanted to address
was not being obese
and then i found it's very easy
to lose a bunch of weight over and over
and over again
and then i wouldn't wouldn't the weight
would all come back
so if i examined um
what the you know common denominator was
there
was like well when i'm losing weight i'm
eating a hell of a lot less
and then you know even if i
continue to be lectin free or gluten
free
or dairy free or whatever free
if i am not eating less than i was
before
i'm gaining weight so i it i just think
if you
if you're if you're sitting back and go
and it can be both
you can have like eczema or irritable
bowel or leaky gut or one of these
things
and also be obese and then maybe you do
have to confront
both of these things the the issue i
have found for myself and for others
is there is a lot of
everybody thinks their way of eating is
the best
and and because this is like again like
almost like a religious or a
philosophical point of view it
tells us informs us so much about who we
are the way we eat it's something we do
every day it's
cultural it's all of these things um
for me travel is only associated with
food
i i can't yeah and then there's some
topographical
things where i think of like oh you know
the countryside new zealand is really
pretty and
you know the the monuments in um
in the in the jungles of southeast asia
are really cool to go and look at but
but really it's
food what am i going to eat what do
those people eat and
what's that trip going to be about that
trip is going to be about food
for me to some degree but i think
you got it you got to like look at
what things you're addressing and how
you're addressing them
and i think for for the most part
obesity is generally
just eating too much and so
if you have and and i'm not saying
any of these diets aren't going to be
workable
for obesity but
you know i wanted to not i wanted to cut
gluten out of my diet i thought that if
i just cut gluten out of my diet i would
be okay and i would lose weight and i
would not gain weight again that's just
not the case
right i had no autoimmune
disease i had no kind of the the
the secondary effects that i was dealing
with was soreness sore back
mental [ __ ] and and and
none of that mental bs was was being
affected by the food
it was all still my relationship with
food and so i would go like
oh i just need to not eat lectins if i
just don't eat lectins
this will handle my food if i just don't
eat gluten this one if i just don't eat
refined sugar
this will handle my relationship with
voodon it just wasn't the case because
my relationship with food
remained the same uh i i could do
keto which was kind of what i fell back
to most often because
every time i got strict on keto
your body excuse me purges all your
glycogen
and you see a rapid weight loss in the
beginning
this is not fat loss this is just
your your carbohydrates cause your
muscles to store
glycogen that's in a fluid weighs a lot
and so
you can go from uh you know
3 000 calories a day with carbs
to 3000 calories a day
on just ketogenic foods and lose weight
it's not
fat it's mostly water this is not a
knock on the keto diet
if you can long-term
re-establish your relationship with food
on the ketogenic diet you're going to be
successful
but you have to know that you can't
consume
the same amount that's causing you to
gain weight now
if gluten or
processed sugar or any of the kind of
inflammatory things
are causing some other effect on you
that is
not something you want then you gotta
address that with that you know you see
what i mean i really do think of them as
two different things
and many people can have issues with
both
so it's gonna take them addressing both
things
i just found that every time i did a
diet
that uh put the the
emphasis on the food rather than on
my responsibility i i eventually failed
hmm okay that's very interesting
um for for my relationship with food
like i was
a huge i don't know foodie is the right
word i don't know
i don't know many people who don't
really like food but i
really liked food and i think part of it
was
and i really do think part of it was
because of the medication i was taking
like i think ssris can really increase
hunger in people
and i was on them since i was 12. and i
noticed when i stopped them that
that really lessened so i think part of
it was that
but i really enjoyed what i ate and i
can remember traveling and being like oh
i wonder what kind of food is there but
it was like
part of the experience while traveling
um
but then when i like switched over and
cut everything that i considered
really palatable out of my diet um
because of because of the arthritis
right
and among many other things it really
changed how i viewed traveling
it really did because i was like and it
doesn't really matter like it doesn't
matter where i go i'm going to be eating
at steak houses
and if you're eating like it's not a
hard it's not a that's not bad right if
you have to eat at one restaurant a
steakhouse isn't that bad a place to
have to eat
but it does remove an aspect of
traveling which is it's kind of sad but
it's also kind of freeing in a way
i did a version of that diet i never was
really truly carnivore but
keto for a long time and yeah you know
to me france was really boring
when i was on keto like there aren't
great steak houses there there's a place
um i'm blanking on the name but all they
serve
is steak and fries with an applause
sauce and
and i would go and eat their steaks and
their steaks were kind of shitty
and the fries were cooked in like steak
fat and i would watch my
wife and my kids happily chow down on
the fries and just think like this
sucks you know this is i want creamed
spinach
and a giant delicious steak um
not the shitty little fake french steak
uh
you know i totally know what you mean i
am i
for a huge portion of my life i was
i was living that way now look i was
doing it
simply because i wanted to lose weight
if if there was a uh
if there was a secondary effect
that was uh occurring because
of carbohydrates or gluten or any of
these things sugar
and i was experiencing that today
this would be a problem for me still but
when i kind of went like i i'm still
not addressing my relationship with food
i'm still
you know waiting till people aren't
looking and cooking a pack of bacon
and eating it when i'm not hungry this
is not
the way to regain
my battle with obesity
what do you think caused this like this
weird relationship with food do you have
any idea
i the only thing that i can locate that
i think
makes any sense at all and and i don't
know if it's true this is just what i
imagine to be true um is that
food was restricted for most of my life
and so the way i got around that was
sneaking food and so i
developed this kind of like you know was
pleasurable for me to eat as much as i
could
when nobody could see me because i
couldn't
otherwise eat the amounts that i wanted
now i go
deep into thinking about this and think
that i
when food be began being restricted for
me i wasn't
obese certainly i was i was overweight
and that was why
i was initially put on diets as a kid
and had i just had i just understood
the point maybe this wouldn't have
happened and i don't sit here and regret
like god i
i had a miserable life because uh
i had you know all this stuff i i i'm
very happy today
i have a wife i have four kids like this
is a great life i'm
and and i don't arrive here without
having
lived everything i lived so so i don't
know but i do
think it was the fact that um
and you know look i also have
you know i think some of these things
are innate like
i'm a drug addict too i don't know if
one thing follows the other or this is
just
me who i am but like my relationship
with alcohol is
pretty much the same as it is with food
i
i when i when i start doing something
the off switch
is muted or dulled or it doesn't exist
so clearly for me
yeah i wonder i wonder how
often those kind of things couple and
what exactly the reason is
for it i've wondered that a lot too
even though like my issues were were
very much
autoimmune um i like i've had
it's really there's so many factors that
go into this kind of thing that it's
really hard to pinpoint
yeah it's really hard to pinpoint okay
i've got some
very specific questions that i thought
might be able to help people
that you might be able to help me with
um
okay what kind of encouragement might
somebody need
to start on a weight loss journey
or a health journey you know i found
that
the idea that it's impossible and and i
think
i think the the thing we run into a lot
here is that
many people have many failures and so
even if it's a small thing even if it's
like i started to die
one day i didn't make it through the day
i'm a failure right
every time you don't succeed at a given
uh on a given course that can build up
and these failures can com
compound and and be become
insurmountable
in your head and so i just think that
if you have to to start very
very small and work on successes
is a good is a good strategy for
building
confidence in success and so
setting a tiny goal like you talked
about it a day at a time this is
this is something i learned in becoming
sober
is that if a day at a time is too much
go to an hour go to a you know a minute
go to a second go to a moment i'm just
gonna make it through
this moment whatever my set
goal is this moment my head
or something external is a roadblock
or a barrier to me being successful and
if i can just
make it through that then that's a
success
and then having somebody to acknowledge
those successes i think is also helpful
you know um i i do find it very
difficult to do all of this stuff
alone in a vacuum i'm not saying it's
impossible
but i think having a community is
is very helpful i think you create a
community for people dealing with the
stuff you're dealing with and that's
[ __ ] invaluable because
sometimes you just need to hear somebody
talk about their experience and you go
like yeah
i have that too i'm not alone and
that's your community or uh a spouse or
a brother or a sister or
somebody um and
and and you can and you can say here's
what i here's what i've been dealing
with and you can get
some feedback from it um so
i i i go to more often than not
setting really small precise goals that
i know i can
beat and then kind of going bigger and
bigger based on that
the reason i started talking about my
experience was because
i it was like i'd been doing it for a
year and a half
and i really had been doing it alone and
i'd
and i'd been doing it alone and i was
getting ridiculed
from people around me and it was so
miserable it was like not only was i
alone and not only was part of me like
do i have a food like an eating disorder
like if nobody
if everyone around me thinks i'm insane
do is this am i insane like because
maybe i'm
maybe i'm insane it's reasons shows
anyway
um it was like a year and a half of
doing that and
i'd been pretty pretty scientific in
tracking my autoimmune flare-ups and
their relationship to what i was eating
and
it had happened like 14 times these
reactions and i was like okay
that's it like it feels like something's
walloping me on the head telling me to
talk about it like i had this
guilt about not sharing it and was like
if there's anybody else out there
that's experiencing these kind of
symptoms like i want to let them know
that they're not alone
because they're not alone and i'm not
crazy like this is definitely happening
and i started my blog then when i was
like this is just
too ridiculous and thank goodness now
there are all these different food
communities that at least you can
at least you can go in and then like
peer around
see what's going on i mean you know
you've been on a whole bunch of diets
you can try it out it might not be what
your problem is
but at least there are people you can
talk to now
and hopefully you don't end up in a
group of people
that just tell you that you know
whatever works for you is wrong
right because right because they don't
know who you are and they don't know
what works
well i think this is a dangerous
position we we find ourselves in today
too
um where when you're doing something
successfully
why you know
don't change it like if you're if what
you're doing is working
and you are happy with it you know
i i think that that's very very tricky
nowadays
um you when you describe
how people think saying you're crazy or
thinking you're crazy like
this this is something that
we get into in all aspects of life and
this is why i think diet is so
interesting
um where it's just like
look dude whatever your value
system is might not be exactly the same
as hers
whatever she's doing is working for her
and clearly working for other people too
like this is not this is not something
that
not even something you invented you know
what i mean like
these these things are quite commonly
talked about
autoimmune and the current western diet
don't seem to be happily existing
together so
changing one and having success and
pinpointing like
oh my god and i had a flare-up when i
did this
this is valuable for a lot of people i
do find it
wild when things are presented as
like you must be wrong because
x y and z right and and it's like but
me and a bunch of people don't find that
to be true it's like
i don't care what you you know eating
animals is wrong and it's like
how what is this value that i don't
share with you that you're telling me i
must you know these things are it's a
wild state
but i love it with diets because at the
end of the day
it doesn't really matter like nobody's
gonna get in trouble
um you know obviously i do think like
there was a big thing
recently i had a friend go like you need
to do a water fast and i'm like oh
water fast tell me about the water fast
and he's like yeah you go like
a month with just drinking water and i'm
like you know
you can't tell everybody to do that that
could be dangerous like we're getting
into a place where objectively this
could be dangerous you know
um because you know i think you probably
found too
we have some responsibility here where
there is minutia
in what we're doing that if we're not
explicitly clear about
people could do it in the wrong way and
not have a good reaction
yeah that's definitely worrisome like
i've
i and i've been especially with the diet
i'm on because it's so restrictive
i was very very very worried about that
at the beginning
so i tried to air into like this is
exactly what i did
and this is exactly what happened to me
and that's the information i'm giving
you
and then i started building more of a
community and then i could say
okay this is what i've seen has worked
for a lot of
people but like you know
get your vitamins tested make sure
you're not deficient in anything
if you're deficient treat the
deficiencies like
every body has different things that's
happened to it and
and like mine particularly is definitely
not the same as anybody else's
even though there's might be
similarities between autoimmune
disorders
but it's tricky when you get a following
uh i dabbled in fasting for a while and
i found it
extremely helpful when i was still kind
of
at the beginning of my journey as i um i
think
this is just this is a theory i have i
can see what you think about this
but i had i had extra weight i didn't
have a lot of extra weight but i
probably had
maybe like 15 or 20 pounds of extra
weight after i had a baby that i
couldn't shake
um and i didn't understand why
and so i did some extended fast and they
made me feel
terrible like pretty terrible i i drank
salt water but
i'd have like a day of not being able to
think very well i can remember putting
my phone in the fridge and being like
i'm putting my phone in the fridge i'm
obviously my brain isn't working very
well
um and then it would get better and then
the more times i did it the easier it
got
until it actually made me feel better
when i was fasting
and then i don't i do i do like natural
intermittent fasting now i haven't done
an extended fast in
like maybe eight months so i don't
really need to do it anymore
but i think what i was doing this is my
theory i think i was getting rid of some
of the
fat i had stored that was storing some
of the medications i'd been on or
toxins and burning through that and
losing that
made me feel bad and then when i like
i've
i've gained weight and lost weight a
little bit even on the carnivore diet
and now fasting is a lot easier
when i'm losing that weight so i guess
this brings me to another question
when you were losing weight did you have
periods of time when losing weight
made you feel bad
um i don't know if in in the way
that we're talking about i it's
it's very tricky because i somehow
whenever uh whenever i go on a super
restrictive diet
i don't know if there's some association
with withholding
so much from myself that i suddenly feel
like i'm back in my first day in rehab
experiencing physical withdrawals from
drugs
but i it could be withdrawal too i had
that
yeah and i'm sure it was like sugar
withdrawal and stuff that was intense
even like
wheat withdrawal if that's a thing i'm
sure it is i think when you're
accustomed to
eating something and your body is used
to it
it's so weird how i could eat
and drink sugar and consume
massive amounts of calories and
basically always
feel the same like i wouldn't wake up
feeling shittier i think i just
always felt shitty and now
when i eat sugar at night or something
like that
i wake up like with a hangover like eyes
stuck together
puffy feeling totally run down
so i think it takes some room uh
to feeling actually good to knowing what
feeling good
feels like to then recognize what
feeling shitty feels like but i think
any of these things are super helpful
with just
understanding that we can be responsible
for this stuff
you know that we have some power over it
yeah and which is also a great feeling
that you have that it's your
taking responsibility for that aspect of
your life
is freeing because it doesn't make you
feel
well it doesn't make you feel like
there's nothing you can do about it
or powerless which is miserable and
like you had weight i had this
autoimmune disorder and it was like
i'm stuck with this forever there's
nothing i'm going to be able to do with
it like i'm going to be on medication
forever
and my joints are slowly going to just
disintegrate like this is
miserable and realizing
you know and then you have the medical
system as well which says yes
you're right you are slowly
disintegrating and there's nothing you
can do about it it's genetic and you're
really unlucky
you're like well if the doctors are all
saying it you know since i'm a kid
then it's probably true and having that
switch where it's like no
you it's your responsibility only like
it's really
only your responsibility which is scary
but it's also incredibly
freeing when you realize you know maybe
there is something i can actually do
about this
yeah the medical system looks more and
more like a shady auto mechanic to me
every day where it's like i went in for
a flat tire and now i need a new
carburetor or whatever it is and it's
like
one pill to fix this and and 14 more
pills to handle the side effects of that
pill and each and
and then we get to the idea of like end
of life
is just all our counter space is filled
with prescription bottles
and you know we just got ailments we
never knew we could have
um i do think uh
quite a bit of the
stuff that we address and listen i say
that as a father to somebody who has
type 1 diabetes and i'm
thankful every day for her insulin and
that there's a pharmaceutical company
that produces it and
charges us way too much money for it
unfortunately but thank god it's there
um so i'm not just a totally
anti-that system but i do think um
quite a bit of this stuff could be
addressed with
how we're eating and what we're eating
and what it's doing to us and
i think that there's all kinds of things
like
imagine just you've talked about it the
host of medications you've been on
that you changed the way you ate
and now are not on like this is a
miraculous thing
yeah yeah it definitely is okay
what made you decide to take
responsibility for your health
it was really it was before i even was
thinking about it in terms of health
it was um this idea that i was in
love with a girl and for the first time
uh
thinking about the future with her there
had been
other instances where i was in
relationships short-term relationships
where uh
i just didn't care the the future didn't
matter like beyond the weekend
i wasn't thinking like what's my life
gonna be like
and with this person i wasn't ever
having thoughts like that and then
i was with this girl and i was like oh
my god i could have a
really nice life with this person
and um i could enjoy her company
forever like i don't think i'm gonna get
sick of this one you know uh
and and i don't want her to get sick of
me and what does that mean
and how do i how do i take charge of
that because
the direction i'm headed in there isn't
much
future the future is like day day-to-day
wondering if i'm going to make it
through the night and not really giving
a [ __ ]
so suddenly i gave a little bit of a
[ __ ] suddenly there was like a fight to
to survive there and have experiences
with her
like um going on a hike which is
something i
never wanted to do because it hurt and
it was not comfortable
um and and it was really looking at life
through that lens that got me to
to start to take responsibility for my
life and then it took a long time
to learn more and more that it was
really up to me
um to to be in charge of that and i say
that like
um i was i was constantly trying to put
the onus on the food
and i think even in in your situation i
still think it's you i don't think it's
the food and
and in that i just mean like you know
what uh is gonna happen if you eat that
thing so you don't eat that thing and
for me it was more just like
i wanted it to be something it wasn't i
wanted it to not be my responsibility
for a long time i was taking
responsibility it was just like the
gradual shift of going from
things are being done to me to
i'm in charge of everything you know the
the day that i
literally woke up going like oh all of
this
everything is up to me all of it that
was the day where i was like oh i can do
anything i can
do anything i want i can have the
muscles i want i can have the cardio i
want i can have the life i want
and it's it's all just entirely me um
that was a big big day for me and that
took a
long time of me still trying to put the
responsibility
into something else
that was amazing that was great that was
perfect
um i think we should end with that
that's what i experienced as well it was
a mindset
the first thing was a mindset change and
it was really like i tried
every way that it was not my
responsibility
and it nothing was working and it was
failing really quickly
yeah like my body was not was not
working really quickly and i was like
[ __ ]
there's nobody that's gonna do this
other than me yeah
and then as soon as i as soon as that
happened it wasn't as
soon but things started improving like
you know like this
in a really rocky way almost right then
yeah yeah i think
i think it's very it's a very difficult
lesson to
tell somebody because until you actually
have it until you see it and what it is
it's it's like um telling somebody how
to ride a bike just ride you know what i
mean like
once you're going you're not gonna fall
down until you think you're gonna fall
down and then you fall down like this
kind of crazy thing but then
you get up on the bike you start
pedaling and you're like oh i understand
this
since i'm doing it um
and then the the formula i think to get
there
is small victories i think for me it was
small
victories i hope that's true for others
um
i i don't know what else to to i don't
know another way to kind of
help people understand the shift from
being
things are happening to me to i am
making everything you know i i am the
the god of my story or whatever however
you want to see this
um but i i think it's i think it's a
really
a really neat thing and um it's so much
fun to watch
other people go through that
okay ethan where can people find you if
they want to find you online
um ethan sipley on instagram
and twitter though in fairness i don't
really
look at twitter other than michael malus
because he's the only one who does
twitter right in my opinion
uh and uh ethan's fleet on instagram and
an american glutton podcast on the
podcast
channels okay thank you very much for
coming on and good luck with your movie
in mexico
thanks for having me i'll talk to you
soon talk to you soon
bye
[Music]
you